[Musique]
il y a vingt ans
nous avons découvert
le monde des sorciers puis à sorciers
harry je suis à bord le sortilège été
lancé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je veux devenir à sorcières
c'est un monde qui enchante notre
quotidien
[Musique]
charme nos sens
et libère notre imagination
vous êtes appelés à faire de grange
rouge
c'est l'occasion de passer du temps avec
des amis
et d'en rencontrer de nouveau
c'est une page de livre
sur une scène
mais sur un écran
à
c'est tout un monde qui
inspire et le nôtre
[Musique]
dites vous bien que tous les grands
sorciers dans l'histoire n'était au
départ
rien de plus que ce que nous sommes en
ce moment les élèves s'ils peuvent le
faire pourquoi pas nous
de nouvelles aventures nous attendent
[Musique]
le monde que nous connaissons ses fruits
ce qui semble inimaginable aujourd'hui
semblerait inévitable demain
si vous acceptez de faire ce que je
demande vous devrez faire confiance
même si votre instinct vous en dissuader